este mismo día hace tres años empezaba
una larga historia para los habitantes
de wuhan el inicio del confinamiento por
un virus el covid-19 ahora un trienio
muchas muertes y contagios después los
ciudadanos finalmente ven la luz al
final del túnel y empiezan a dejar el
miedo atrás
creo que todo el mundo ha vuelto a ser
como hace tres años la gente hace su
vida se reúne con la familia y los
amigos sale a jugar y a viajar y es
feliz muchas cosas han vuelto ahora
muchas de nuestras preocupaciones y las
depresiones se han ido desvaneciendo
poco a poco
este famoso mercado de buján en su día
sospechoso de ser el epicentro del brote
ahora permanece clausurado para el
público la noticia llegó por sorpresa en
plena noche de ese enero 2020 el
gobierno anunció el confinamiento que
duró 76 días los bujaneses tuvieron que
enfrentarse a escenas duras desde Cuerpo
sin vida en la calle hasta la carga
psicológica de estar encerrados por un
virus que apenas conocían
al principio no tenía tanto miedo pero
poco a poco tras el encierro empezamos a
preocuparnos un poco pero esas duras
políticas hicieron que no nos
contagiáramos durante el más de un mes
de encierro Así que fue bastante bueno
desde ese momento en 2020 el cobi 19 ha
puesto en aprietos al planeta cobrándose
la vida de millones de personas y
desplomando las economías mundiales no
obstante en wuhan una vez ciudad
Fantasma La vida ha vuelto a la
normalidad y a pesar de que el virus se
siga cobrando miles de vidas en el país
después a que el gobierno de chillimpín
decidiera poner fin a su estricta
política de cero covid